- Mein Name ist Elkart Abdelmalek.
Ich arbeite als Gebäudereiniger.
- Ich bin Jannik Buchhorst, gelernter
Gebäudereiniger,
mit Leib und Seele bin ich dabei.
- Mein Name ist Ingrid Buchholz.
Ich bin seit acht Jahren
bei der Firma Clean Service
Power tätig als Bereichsleitung.
- Als Gebäudereiniger lernt man
Glasreinigung, Fassadenreinigung …
- … Graffitientfernung, Teppich-
shampoonierung, Grundreinigung …
- … und Schädlingsbekämpfung.
Das sind so die Hauptthemen.
- Bei der Gebäudereinigung gibt es
verschiedene Aufgaben,
zum Beispiel die Unterhaltsreinigung.
Reinigungskräfte putzen Büros,
saugen Böden
und machen die Sanitäranlagen sauber.
Die Gebäudereiniger haben meist
speziellere Aufgaben.
Sie reinigen Glasfassaden,
entfernen Graffitis
und säubern Teppiche.
Sie benutzen spezielle Maschinen
und Reinigungsmittel.
Mehr über den Beruf des Gebäudereinigers
erfahrt ihr im nächsten Teil.
- Ich bin der Herr Elkart, das ist
mein Team. Heute reinigen wir die Bank.
Jetzt laden wir das Material aus.
Wir haben heute den Auftrag
hier bei der Bank.
Wir haben die Fassadenreinigung
auf Position eins,
Position zwei haben wir Graffitientfernung,
Position drei haben wir
Teppichshampoonierung
und Position vier haben wir Fleck-
entfernung bei der Teppichshampoonierung.
Also du nimmst die erste Position:
Teppichflecken,
Teppich shampoonieren.
Ich mache mit Alex die Fassadenreinigung
und die Graffitientfernung.
- Okay, alles klar.
Weiß ich Bescheid.
- Okay.
Dann legen wir los.
- Mit dieser Maschine machen wir heute
die Fassadenreinigung.
Komm mal her!
Einmal das blaue Kabel
[den blauen Schlauch],
der ist für das neutralisierte Wasser
und kommt hier rein.
Und das ist das schwarze Kabel
[der schwarze Schlauch],
der ist für „Chemie“, der kommt an
den zweiten Adapter dran.
Das wird so gebaut.
Und die Schnur [der Klettverschluss]
muss immer so gedreht werden,
damit das Kabel [der Schlauch]
nicht hin- und hergeht.
Jannik, dreh mal bitte das Wasser auf.
Laufen lassen, einmal hier starten.
Nur am Knopf drehen,
und jetzt geht’s los.
Kürzen wir ab, Jannik. Abkürzen.
Also, es wird immer abgekürzt, wenn wir
die Hälfte der Fenster gemacht haben.
Einmal danach kurz runterdrehen.
Einmal zum Ausmachen den Knopf drücken,
dass das Gerät aus ist. Okay.
- Und dann die Flüssigkeit auf den Mopp.
Das Wasser ein bisschen nachfüllen.
Und dann schön auf die Fassade einreiben.
Wenn du möchtest, kannst du
es ja auch mal machen.
Genau so.
- Jetzt nimmst du die zweite Variante.
Ein bisschen Chemie auf den Schwamm.
Das, was da noch geblieben ist,
kriegst du damit weg.
- Auf den Schwamm drauf.
Tust noch mehr drauf, genau, richtig so.
Genau.
Vielleicht versuchst du mal kreisende
Bewegungen - warte mal -
kreisende Bewegungen ...
kreisende Bewegungen sind besser,
dass es auch schön in die Poren reingeht.
Siehst du?
Siehst du noch etwas?
Lass mich noch mal dran bitte.
Ja, so, jetzt ist der Arbeitsvorgang
beendet, wir sind fertig.
- So, jetzt haben wir alles zusammen.
Jetzt können wir den Teppich sauber machen.
Jetzt bauen wir das erst mal alles auf.
Rein damit! So.
Das ist das Erste, der Treibteller.
Das ist der Treibteller.
Dann müssen wir die Maschine
ein bisschen kippen.
Da kann man schon sehen: einmal rein,
so, und einmal drehen.
Jetzt ist es fest. Okay?
- Hab ich verstanden.
- Alles klar.
Dann kommt das Pad drauf,
und dann kippen wir das wieder zurück.
Und der erste Vorgang ist fertig.
Jetzt müssen wir das alles anschließen.
Das saugt das Wasser ein
und die Chemie später.
- Und hier?
- Das ist fürs klare Wasser,
noch zum Nachspülen.
Dann musst du ziehen, bis es klickt.
Dann müssen wir das hier oben auch
anschließen.
Hier einmal.
Also, das schmutzige Wasser später zum
Neutralisieren kommt dann hier rein.
So ...
Und dann müssen wir das aufmachen.
Da kommt das klare Wasser rein.
So!
Dann kommt jetzt hier Wasser rein in
die Einscheibenmaschine.
So.
Jetzt haben wir hier Chemie:
Teppichreiniger.
- Kommt auch hier rein?
- Hier kommt jetzt Chemie rein,
das ist Teppichreiniger
Für den Fleck hier.
Nicht zu viel.
Wir starten.
Siehst du, wie das Wasser jetzt
da unten rauskommt?
Immer kreisende Bewegungen machen,
dass du auch jede Pore mit Chemie füllst.
Dann wenn man hier fertig ist,
geht man ein bisschen runter.
Wo man hier den Fleck sieht –
mehr Chemie drauf und
länger draufbleiben auf dem Fleck.
So, jetzt sieht man hier keine Flecken mehr,
dann kann man die Einscheibenmaschine
auf Seite tun.
Jetzt sind wir mit dem ersten
Arbeitsvorgang fertig.
Stellen wir die ab.
Jetzt kommt das nächste Gerät.
Also, hiermit saugen wir jetzt das …
… die Chemikalien weg.
Also, es kommt vorher das klare Wasser,
und dann saugt man beides ab sozusagen.
Hier muss man gleich draufdrücken.
So.
Und dann wird das dann alles
sauber gemacht.
Ich mach das jetzt an.
Für den Wassersauger und
für das klare Wasser zum Nachspülen.
Langsam.
So, willst du mal versuchen?
- Ja!
- So, ihr Graffiti ist entfernt.
- Sehr schön gemacht, sehr gut!
- Die Fassade da oben, die Glasreinigung
ist auch fertig gemacht.
- Sehr schön.
- Dann müssen wir uns nur noch
den Teppich angucken.
So, der Fleck ist weg,
der Teppich sieht wie neu aus.
- Das ist sehr schön gemacht,
gefällt mir sehr gut.
- Das ist schön, freut mich.
Also, wir haben uns jetzt die ganzen
Positionen angeguckt,
Position eins: Graffitientfernung.
Position zwei: Fassadenreinigung.
Haben wir ja auch kontrolliert.
Glasreinigung haben wir ja
auch kontrolliert.
Teppichshampoonierung haben wir
jetzt auch kontrolliert.
Brauch ich noch bitte ein Autogramm.
- Ja natürlich.
- So, vielen Dank. Müssen wir noch einen
Termin vereinbaren wegen der Glasreinigung?
- Ja, ich denke 14.8.,
das ist ein Montag.
Wird es dann werden.
- Kein Problem, halten wir fest.
- Halten wir so fest.
Also vielen Dank.
- Alles klar, bis 14.8.!
- Danke, schönen Tag noch!
- Schönen Tag noch, tschüss!
- Als Gebäudereiniger muss man
sehr achten auf Sicherheit.
- Für Steigerarbeiten muss man
sich anschnallen,
bei Gondeln muss ich meinen
Sicherheitsgurt tragen und mich anschnallen.
Bei Leiterarbeiten muss immer
einer unten festhalten,
damit derjenige nicht umkippt.
- Wenn man mit Chemie arbeitet,
muss man aufpassen,
dass man die Dosierung richtig hat,
dass die Böden nicht kaputtgehen
und auch auf seine eigene Sicherheit,
das heißt, man muss Handschuhe tragen
und eine Brille.
- Sie müssen gut sein im Umgang
mit Kunden.
Manchen Objekte sind halt auch so,
dass die Kunden vor Ort sind.
Sie müssen freundlich sein,
sie müssen auf den Kunden
eingehen können,
sie müssen, wenn der Kunde mit
irgendeinem Problem zu ihnen kommt,
eine Lösung haben – sollten sie haben.
Aber dafür sind wir dann halt eben da,
um ihnen das halt beizubringen.
- Das Schönste als Gebäudereiniger ist,
dass man viel rumkommt,
dass man viele nette Arbeitskollegen hat
und dass man immer was lernt,
was man noch nicht wusste.
Also der Job ist nicht monoton.
- Ich habe keine Ausbildung gemacht,
sondern ich hab mich angestrengt,
Erfahrung gesammelt in 20 Jahren.
- Wir beschäftigen halt Mitarbeiter,
die keine Erfahrung haben
in der Gebäudereinigung. Die werden von
uns dann halt eingewiesen und angelernt,
dass man ihnen halt das Optimum
mitgeben kann,
wie eine Reinigung auszuführen ist.
Bei uns kann man auch eine Ausbildung
starten zum Gebäudereiniger.
Die Ausbildung dauert drei Jahre,
und danach hat man halt
eben die Möglichkeit,
als Bereichsleiter zum Beispiel
[zu arbeiten] oder halt selber
irgendwelche Häuser zu leiten.
Oder bestenfalls halt auch eventuell
sogar einen Meister zu machen
und den weiteren Schritt dann halt zur
Selbstständigkeit [zu gehen].
- Ein guter Gebäudereiniger muss
schnell und gründlich arbeiten.
- In meinem Job mach ich alles gerne.
Da macht mir alles Spaß.